this video is made possible by blinkist
there are so many great books out there
that we all want to read but
so often fitting in reading carrying a
book or reading on a screen
is a hassle blinkist solves that problem
by condensing the key points of more
than 4
500 non-fiction titles you can choose to
either listen to them or read the
summaries points or both
that means that i could be finding out
everything about the intelligent
investor
without having to read this massive book
while i'm going for a run or even
cooking dinner the app lets you save
your playlist
and will offer suggestions based on the
titles you enjoy whether that's history
psychology or tools for entrepreneurs
they also have a selection of abridged
podcasts delivering the key points in 15
minutes or less
but the best thing is that you can
access the library offline making
blinkist the perfect beach read
if this sounds like something you'd be
into the first 100 people to go to
blinkist.com
forward slash visualpolitik are going to
get unlimited access for one week to try
it out
you'll also get 25 off if you decide you
want to continue with the four
membership
don't forget that blinkist seven day
trial is completely free
and that you can cancel at any time
during the trial if you're not
completely into it
but i'm sure you will be so click on the
link in the description
and check it out today and now for
today's video
let's be honest one year after the
outbreak of covid19 we have all become
even if only a little bit pandemic
experts let's see who dares to tell me
that they've never had a discussion
about this or that vaccine about pcrs
antigen tests or the origin of the virus
probably none of you but while it may
seem that we already know the name and
surname of all the vaccines there are
i'm sure that in this video you'll
discover something new tell me have you
ever heard of the uzbek chinese vaccine
i bet you haven't we're talking about a
vaccine that has been registered in
uzbekistan under the name
zfuzzak 2001 as a reminder but don't
worry because today
we're not going to get into biochemistry
what interests me is to take a closer
look at this odd relationship
china and uzbekistan why did they decide
to produce this vaccine together what
exactly is it that unites these two
countries in this video we've got a lot
to talk about and we won't only be
talking about uzbekistan
we're heading to a part of the world
where everyone decided to give their
countries the same suffix we're talking
about kazakhstan uzbekistan kyrgyzstan
tajikistan and turkmenistan or in other
words
central asia this region has been in the
sights of the great powers since the
19th century and today the situation has
not changed much these days the
competition for influence is now between
russia the united states
turkey india pakistan and of course
china beijing has been investing in the
stars for years
it builds infrastructure sends its
workforce and controls a very high
percentage of the foreign debt of these
countries and that is precisely what we
are going to look at what is china doing
in central asia who stands to gain and
is this region of the world becoming the
new field of expansion of the
re-emerging chinese empire well let's
get started
[Music]
as you may have already suspected in
this video we're going to talk a lot
about money this is one of the most
unequal divisions
in the world for example none of you
will be surprised that if i tell you
that china's gdp
is 50 times that of all the central
asian countries combined comparing china
with for example tajikistan is like
talking about david and goliath
of course in this case david and goliath
are not fighting but trading
this is not so unusual after all we're
talking about neighboring countries and
it would be strange if they did not have
any kind of commercial relationship but
the truth is that china is also one of
central asia's main investors
and creditors and of all of them it is
the energy sector that interests it most
chinese firm to build kazakh hydro power
plant joc
xam bank of china allocates loan to
uzbek bank to modernize hpp
energy central and that's not all we
will look at it later but i can already
tell you that several routes of the new
silk road pass precisely through central
asia beijing is also building and
financing the transportation
infrastructure such as roads and
railroads that it needs to ensure the
transit of its products
remember however that we are talking
about countries with little or no
democracy in which corruption
simply reigns with absolute power so
many times the money disappears into the
official statistics themselves
that's why foreign investments are a
risky bet and even china has been burned
already more than once so lately it's
engaged in smaller projects
some factories and cement plants or
mines yielding gold copper
zinc and other natural resources
then on the other hand beijing is also
financing the construction of schools
and colleges where chinese is studied
in these countries it is open in
confucius institutes throughout the
region and even has several scholarship
programs in place so that central asian
students can do academic
exchanges in china this is an example of
the expansion of soft power the new
reality of chinese influence that we
in the west are still unaware of but is
gaining more and more influence
in total over the past 15 years china
has allocated 54 billion
to investment and construction in
central asia that is about the same as
the entire gdp of uzbekistan but you may
be thinking by now that central asia's
relationship with china is only about
money well the truth is that they have
something else in common their passion
for technology and control
tell me what name would you give to a
project that consists of constant
surveillance and facial recognition well
in the finest orwellian style it is
called safe
cities and i don't know if you like the
idea but i can tell you who loves it
tajikistan and uzbekistan are already
developing their safe cities programs
with huawei obviously the concept of
security involves ensuring the security
of the bigwigs in power and continuing
with tajikistan we can't ignore one more
aspect in its relations with china we're
talking about the military prisons
in central asia's forbidding highlands a
quiet newcomer chinese troops
wp you probably already know that china
has military bases in djibouti
and in the south china sea but the one
in tajikistan is its first appearance in
central asia and it has to do with the
security on the afghan border look at
this map you are looking at the triple
border between china tajikistan and
afghanistan in the wakan corridor the
first chinese military base in central
asia
is located in the tajik territory very
close to this point
it may not seem so important to you but
for china it is a milestone and a major
step forward until now its relations
with the region were limited to the
economic side but china's influence is
growing
and now it's gunning to take on a new
role in recent months beijing has not
missed the opportunity to strengthen its
influence in central asia with a new
type of diplomacy that involving
vaccines if you recall we started this
video talking about the uzbek chinese
vaccine developed by the chinese
biopharmaceutical company
anhui zephi long com sorry if i
mispronounced that completely wrong and
the chinese academy of sciences and
you're probably thinking
if both institutions are chinese what
does uzbekistan have to do with it
well this is where the interesting part
begins uzbekistan was one of the
countries that participated in the
trials of this vaccine as did for
example
ecuador and pakistan but in february 21
this happened the chinese company
recognized uzbekistan as a co-author of
the development of the zf 2001 vaccine
uz daily uzbekistan officially became
the co-author of the vaccine thanks to
and i quote it's contribution and effort
we don't know whether pakistan and
ecuador didn't make enough effort but it
took
less than two weeks for the following
news to come to light
uzbekistan approves chinese-developed
covert 19 vaccine
reuters it was the first central asian
country to do so thus opening the
region's doors to chinese vaccines soon
after kyrgyzstan and turkmenistan
approved sino-farm and tajikistan is
waiting to receive its sinovac
in central asia everything is
increasingly revolving around china so
why is china so interested in central
asia and vice versa what did the stan
stands to gain from the asian giant
listen up
the fine print
if you're a regular follower of
visualpolitik you need not be reminded
that chinese foreign policy today is
nothing like what it was 50 years ago
that's the thing about being a country
with a much larger and more prosperous
economy well
as far as central asia is concerned
china started to gain prominence
in the 1990s
remember that until 1991 the stars were
part of the soviet union and at the
latter stage
sino-soviet relations left much to be
desired so from that point on beijing
has had to solve the most trivial
problems with its new neighbours how to
define the borders or what to do about
the civil war in tajikistan but the main
change
came in the 2000s when china began to
invest the enormous amounts of dollars
it was accumulating
thanks to its huge trade surplus around
the world
but why exactly central asia well
basically for three reasons
take a look
on the one hand china shares more than 3
000 kilometers of border with kazakhstan
kyrgyzstan and tajikistan and also has
much in common with the countries in the
region for example
in the early 1990s one out of every 1
000 people in china
was kazak tajik uzbek or kegs on the
other hand
since 1993 china has consumed more
energy than it produces
in other words it needs to import it so
the stands have become a crucial source
of oil and gas for beijing and thirdly
in 2013
china announced the creation of the new
silk road therefore central asia became
a key territorial route to connect
chinese products with european markets
but since i think this is more or less
clear let's move on to the next question
what does central asia gain from its
relationship with china
[Music]
well you see here it should be taken
into account that after the collapse of
the ussr
the stans became the poorest countries
in the entire post-soviet space for
decades they had highly interconnected
production systems and were basically
monoculture economies
that is they were highly specialized in
a few products that they produced on a
large scale to supply the rest of the
republics but then all of that collapsed
then again if only all
of central asia's problems were economic
but that's not the case because except
for kyrgyzstan on the political level
they are all examples of
non-democratization we're talking about
regimes that work in a leader-centric
way and have no concern for human rights
add to that the endemic corruption and
you have a pretty good picture of a
region in which few would want to invest
that is why china's cash injection was
like mana from the heaven for central
asia moreover
beijing's money is not conditional on
political reforms or anything like that
and furthermore by developing new roads
and gas pipelines to the east thanks to
chinese money the stans are reducing
their historical dependence on russia so
far it might seem like a perfect
relationship but remember to always
read the fine print in its relations
with central asia china dictates the
terms
as a result many contracts involve the
use of chinese machinery the employment
of chinese labor and the resolution of
potential disputes in chinese courts and
of course we're talking about china
which is not exactly a country that
plays at being the most popular
starting with working conditions that
are often downright poor so
don't think it's all plain sailing in
the last two years the region has seen
more than 40 demonstrations against
chinese expansion
sometimes they've had direct
consequences china led
280 million dollar kurzican project to
abandoned after protests
reuters in any case generally speaking
anti-chinese sentiment has grown
more in kazakhstan and kyrgyzstan
countries where roughly one-third of the
population
has a negative opinion of the asian
giant in contrast china is much better
viewed in the two countries with which
he does not border uzbekistan and
turkmenistan of course in this region of
the world public opinion is
far from representing official positions
and if china has won anything it is the
hearts of the elites you come to
understand that
lack of transparency is a great ally for
corruption often there is no way of
knowing how much money evaporates along
the way without a trace in other words
china's huge line of credit is very good
for the political bigwigs in central
asia to collect their cut and that is
one of the reasons why these projects
often fail to perform as expected and
then of course
there's what happens when it's time to
pay back the loans
[Music]
china does not forgive debts
in economics external debt amounts to
all the obligations that a state has
with other countries or with foreign
institutions
for example the credit offered by the
exim bank of china the export
import bank of china translates into
foreign debt for the countries receiving
these credits as you can imagine there
is no central asian country exempt from
debt to china beijing controls 42
percent of the kirk's foreign debt
40 percent of the tajik one 20 of the
uzbek one and ten percent of the kazakh
one as far as turkmenistan goes we
cannot give you any data because public
statistics
are not exactly the forte of its regime
what is clear is that the most indebted
countries are also the two
poorest in the region kyrgyzstan and
tajikistan and you may ask
why is china lending so much money to
countries that may not be able to pay it
back well in the world of international
relations there are theories for
everything for example
four years ago the academic brahma
chelani presented his own
which is called debt trap diplomacy in a
nutshell it says that china does not
expect to recoup the loans it offers to
underdeveloped countries
instead it intends to create a bond of
political dependence and even challenge
the sovereignty of these states
of course this is only one theory
obviously china is neither the devil nor
is central asia or
any other country in the world obliged
to accept its funding to simply apply
the theory of debt trap
diplomacy would imply exempting local
elites from any responsibility perhaps
the problem is the perverse incentive
that corruption generates
something like i'll take my cut now and
we'll see how the state pays for its
share later the fact
is that each country is looking for ways
to cope with the ever-increasing chinese
debt for example turkmenistan is selling
gas below market price
kazakhstan which borders china's
xinjiang region is keeping a low profile
in the face of the persecution of the
uyghurs but perhaps the most interesting
cases are those of tajikistan and
kyrgyzstan for these two countries one
of the most common ways of repaying the
debt to china is by ceding the rights to
exploit natural resources
and that is why we can find new stories
like this tajikistan ratifies transfer
of gold mines to chinese
for ghana as of today up to 80 percent
of pajam's gold mines are under the
control of chinese companies but not
only that
because there are rumors that
tajikistan's reluctance to join the
eurasian economic union which we've
already covered in a separate video that
i'll link in the description is
precisely due to beijing's interests
and the icing on the cake in 2011 the
tajik parliament
ratified a new protocol on border
delimitation whereby
china received more than 1 000 square
kilometers in the pami mountain range
that is almost one percent of the entire
territory of tajikistan china
does not forgive its debts
[Applause]
kyrgyzstan's situation is even worse
like the other central asian countries
its economy is heavily dependent on
remittances which account for more than
30 percent of gdp that is why the
coronavirus pandemic was such a blow to
the country and now it's even more
difficult for it to pay off its debt to
china which also contributes around 30
of its gdp so do you think you can guess
what the official proposal was to deal
with this debt
ready here it is account for transfer of
funds to repay external debt
opened in kyrgyzstan 24.kg you heard
that correctly kirk's ministry of
finance has opened up a bank account for
anybody to contribute to paying the
country's foreign debt
and the most significant point is that
this is not the first time it's happened
either in 2007 the then president
attenbayev also opened a similar bank
account
at that time the external debt was lots
of ones nines
and zeros basically almost two billion
dollars
now how much money do you think he
received well evidently not much
no more than three thousand three
hundred and fifty dollars in 2020 they
did a little bit better twelve thousand
dollars which is hardly a drop in the
bucket compared to kyrgyzstan's foreign
debt for the time being the country has
no choice but to continue to deepen its
dependence on china and now the question
is over to you what do you think about
this crowdfunding idea do you know about
china's role in central asia is it
possible to take advantage of china's
credits without becoming dependent you
can leave your answers down in the
comments and you know if you found this
video interesting
don't forget to like and subscribe to
visualpolitik all the best see you in
the next month